des longs cours à cannes il n'y a qu'un
pas romane et les halons franchi en
remportant le concours europcar parmi
dix projets sélectionnés récompense pour
les deux réalisatrices en herbe de 3 i/s
un ticket pour le festival du cinéma et
surtout une montée des célèbres marches
comme les grands du métier un rêve pour
ces deux étudiantes en audiovisuel
le festival de cannes pour moi ça
représente bas le rêve du cinéma qui est
concrétisé une fois qu'on a travaillé
très dur et qu'on présente un film ou
conviennent en voir c'est vraiment
l'aboutissement d'un rêve s'est
construit par le parrain réalisateurs
comme par les autres qui va le voir
principe du concours non plus réalisé un
court métrage comme les années
précédentes mais proposer un spot
publicitaire d'une minute faisant la
promotion du groupe de location de
véhicules basée à voisins le bretonneux
les ironman se sont distingués avec
escapade littoral une vidéo qui invite
au voyage
c'est un voyage quand même initiatique
pour une personne qui qui part en voyage
et se découvre elle même tout au long de
ce voyage là et du coup c'est un spot
digital d'une minute dans lequel on
donne aussi envie aux spectateurs de
voyager et de tête se découvrir aussi
aux maires d'autres étudiants de
l'institut de l'image et du son 6 plus
exactement sont à cannes depuis le début
du festival pour travailler
guillaume ulysse agathe camille
alexandre et gwenaëlle sont en stage au
département audiovisuel du festival et
grâce à un partenariat avec leur école
ils ont dans ce cadre plusieurs missions
ça peut aller de filmer la montée des
marches de certains films le soir ou
bien de courir des master class des
rendez vous avec des personnalités
connues du cinéma le tout la journée
on a également des présentations de
films classiques dans le cadre de cannes
classics et quelquefois également allés
filmer le les événements qui assurent le
cinéma de la plage de découvrir vraiment
le festival le palais de l'intérieur
c'est assez impressionnant ce que non on
le voit que de l'extérieur à la télé las
d'être vraiment au coeur du festival
c'est c'est vraiment très sain une
expérience et des souvenirs plein la
tête qu'ils ramèneront dans leurs
bagages